teach kids how to learn i think it's the
most important than teaching them what
to learn i think the actions speak a lot
louder than the words
what does the ideal school or education
look like one of the things that i loved
about my mom
all right everybody so chrissy matthew
in the house uh she's she's an awesome
member of movement maker she's been with
us now for over a year and as part of
that we're doing in uh
an interview together so she's going to
interview me she's had some questions on
her mind and
oh
so yeah i've just been there's certain
things that i've meant to ask you from
about your website and you know your
story is on your website and and since
the beginning so like at the top
you say it's not your fault right and so
my first question is like you throughout
school were you know struggled you went
through three different schools had
challenges
and
you said is one of the things that it's
not your fault you know society
you've been limited people tell you what
to do what to be be realistic
at what point do you think that adults
start
telling young people to
that you know don't dream big anymore
it's not uh you know
you know be realistic type thing a
couple of the things that you had said
on there and why do you think that is
yeah and what what a start um
and i know you do a lot of work with
kids so this is a great this is a great
kind of theme into it um
honestly i think it's even before they
say anything i think if you ask the
parent
who's got a six-year-old or a
seven-year-old or an eight-year-old and
and the kid wants to go and be
a whatever i think when they're really
young the parents are we're usually
pretty encouraging
like yeah you can go do anything you
want and it's and it they have to take
it more seriously once they're looking
at university and college and graduate
in high school and like what courses are
going to pick but i think
even more than the words people say is
the actions that they're doing and so if
you have a six-year-old at home when
you're you're teaching her to go and and
do whatever you want and be you could be
xyz but then you're not living it
yourself
i think the actions speak a lot louder
than the words
and so uh a lot of parents i think are
not off just most people most people are
not living the life that they want most
people are not chasing down they've got
goals they've got aspirations they've
got dreams and they're not taking the
steps to do it and so you can say
something to your kid but if you're not
off demonstrating improving it
i think your kids are much more likely
to see how you act as opposed to listen
to what you're saying
uh and so that then the challenge
becomes okay what would
you know if you won't do it for yourself
for the parents out there if you won't
do it for yourself
your kids because they're so true so
true because you know
obviously even with adults who lead by
action you know we we are the example of
what young people
um look up to and then when they see
especially their parents what they do
do you incorporate your son in a lot of
what you do in your business
only what he wants you know i think like
the the best part about my parents is
they always gave us the freedom to do
whatever
we wanted to go chase down there there
was expectations that we would do
something but not expectations to do
something specific
right it's like we had to go we had to
go chase down goals and learn and
improve but all three of us have two
sisters want to go do different crazy
things
and so with my son people ask me what
you expecting to be an entrepreneur he's
like no right what does he want to do
right now he's doing
his you know he's uh turning 13 in a
couple weeks
and just looking at the date uh turning
13. so i'm going to have a teenager soon
and he's in his his big things are
acting in minecraft
and
we had some entrepreneur stuff like we
had him do
lemonade stand and uh went to my daint
studio and he was selling lemonade
outside there and maybe maybe
entrepreneurship comes back in some way
um
for making videos sometimes he wants to
be part of it sometimes he doesn't so
you know like you basically make it what
are you interested in because when you
when you care about something you're
much more likely to learn and so he
loves
he loves acting and he loves minecraft
so on our on our last school break i
took him to california and we went to
hollywood
and we you know i don't care about
hollywood but we went to hollywood to
show him the hollow walk of fame and to
take him through the highlight was the
universal studios kind of behind the
scenes studio tour
because at least right now that's what
he's into
you know he's 13.
don't have to have him know what he
wants how do you introduce
new things to him right because we see a
lot of young people who are saying you
know i don't want to do that because i
don't like it yet they've never
actually
tried it right so
how do you feel that it's a good way to
introduce something new because you
wouldn't necessarily know about it or
not had their parent not or an adult not
introduced it to them i think kids are
being exposed to way more new things
than what we as parents
that's true
you know like just
from what they watch on youtube you know
they're exposed though i'm asking my son
and my nieces and nephews for like new
things to do right what new videos are
you watching what new music should i
listen to what new things are trending
i'm asking them for what's new as
opposed to me
teaching them what's new
um i think the key thing is is listening
being involved
in their lives and things that they care
about as opposed to the things that
might want them to care about so
instead of
forcing my son to go
learn piano
or trumpet or something um he he really
cares about minecraft he got into it and
so i joined him on minecraft you know i
suck at minecraft i've i i don't i
didn't know the first time i played
minecraft i dug myself into a hole and
couldn't figure out how to do that like
this game is stupid
but but i i learned and i got better and
i improved and and there's a lot of
creativity in minecraft that if i didn't
know what it was it's easy to judge it
as just a waste of time or another video
game or something and
so because he's interested in it we
spend time like it's hard you know kids
don't want to just sit down and talk
about their life i guess at least when
you're 13 years old 12 years old right
maybe when they're older we'll see but
they don't want to just sit down and and
when you ask them hey how was your day
fine yeah you do nothing
and so how do you have conversations and
how do you how do you lead them and how
do you guide them and mentor them i
think it's through shared
activities shared experiences so
if you want to show bouncing back after
failure you know if i'm
if i'm playing minecraft and i got my
full netherright gear which is hard to
get and then i die and i lose all of it
right and i'm starting over then what
happens do i rage quit do i yell at my
computer do i blame the creeper that
blew me out right or is it okay that
sucks
yeah
deep breath we're starting over right
and like it that is demonstrating the
life lesson i think you could teach life
lessons through anything and if they
actually care about that thing then now
i'm demonstrating how to be an adult i
guess uh as opposed to having to be
through
the things that i learned through so i
don't have to teach through
entrepreneurship but through books or
through piano and teach it through the
things that they actually care about
we're looking at uh
trying to do one of one of the things
that i loved about my mom is every
year she took one of the three of us to
something
that we cared about
and so when she took me it was to done
eating florida to go to spring training
toronto blue jays
uh because you get to you get to meet
the players in the parking lot and see
them you know i love baseball and she
kind of cared about baseball but it
wasn't really her thing was my thing so
we're looking at how do we do that for
um for my son but also for my nieces and
nephews they they lost their mom a year
and a half ago and uh you know my wife
has kind of become
the pseudo mom and so they're
a lot more than just
nieces and nephews now um and so we're
looking at what's one thing that that i
could take them to every year and
just be about them
so my niece just turned 16 and she loves
anime
i know nothing about anime like i zero
about anime but but i'm researching like
one of the anime conferences and
conventions coming up that
there's one coming up in la and i'm
going to talk to her this weekend and
maybe that becomes a thing that i take
her to let's go spend three days in la
at the anime conference and uh and i'll
get into it you know
maybe i'm dressing up maybe i'm standing
in line waiting to do a selfie with like
whoever
famous person is and it's not about me
it's about the experience with her and
on that you know trying to sit down and
talk to her about life is is challenging
but when you experience a trip together
and we're spending three days it's just
just me and her
for three days doing something she cares
about there'll be lots of opportunities
for connection um and understanding and
listening and life lessons inside of
that for sure
for sure so yeah
like
actually caring and being interested in
the things that they're interested in as
opposed to the things that you so true i
love that so
you you at leah mentioned before you had
said that you you were slow you know you
found it difficult a little bit school
you went to three different schools
um you had trouble making friends from
time to time and you weren't getting the
extra attention that you needed
a lot of times um there's a lot of young
people today that feel that way
and so
a lot of teachers and i have been one
that included had said you know well
you know they just have difficulty
learning however we know from you
jim quick many other people young kids
it was just the way that they were
learning that was difficult
for them
what do you think is a good way for
teachers education instruction to happen
today
that what you think would have made a
difference if it was a little bit
different when you were in school well
one i had a undiagnosed hearing problem
and it led me to like i would sit under
my desk and clap during school
like the teacher would be teaching
something and i
you know i don't i don't remember this
anymore but like this is what my parents
i would sit under the desk at school
instead of sitting in my chair i would
sit under the desk at school
and and not pay attention and they
thought i was
like ignoring them or a bad student and
really like i just couldn't hear
anything and so instead of sitting there
feeling dumb i try to do something on my
own um
i think that is a challenge in that
teachers have so many kids in a
classroom and to spend individual time
with everybody becomes you know
challenging but it's you know on the
parents too then internet didn't exist
when that was me right now
however old now now you can um so maybe
they have actually something
physically wrong or emotionally wrong or
something going on at home that it's not
actually a learning problem it's just
right
they're stressed out or they have a
physical problem that you know needs to
be solved um
the second would be and i mean again
just for that it's like creating a safe
space and taking the time to actually
care like i tell the story of madame
farr who is my teacher
mentor my last year of high school and i
went from being a bnc student to a
straight 90s student after
meeting her once a week
i was the same person you know it's just
like that extra support and and belief
and having somebody to help me was great
um and then second is just understanding
how you learn so
i'm auditory is the worst way for me
um
i i like to learn by seeing something
and i like to learn with having somebody
kind of guide me and so my whole
history of feeling like a dummy and
stupid and can't learn was really oh i
just
can't learn that way i need to have i
need to have a guide and when i have a
guide and i can actually see it right
i'm actually a great learner
but i didn't understand that until it
was like in my 20s so you know that's uh
if we can learn that earlier uh i think
it'd be a great gift that we can give i
agree with you
in that sense i think that that's one of
the biggest
um issues today with education and you
know yes there's a lot of different kids
in the in the class but you know it's
still
the system itself is still that one
track system
um that only works for one-third of kids
and so
um
so yeah it's interesting to hear that
because it's really just an alteration
of how the materials presented or how
you learn that would have made such a
big difference now going to piggyback on
your you were assigned madame farr
miss miss
and she was your mentor in grade 12
right
and she made you believe in yourself you
were just like oh my gosh like
you said you had got straight a's and
and you it made all the difference
why do you think like what do you not
why what do you think would have
happened
had
you been assigned a mentor
in grade nine
yeah it would have made all the
difference in the world and and um i
i think what i i moved between madame
foreign because her we actually i called
her madam far but most people don't
understand what was she a french teacher
you try to say mrs far sometimes
yeah yeah she was my french teacher uh
and
i went to a french immersion school
there was the third school that i went
the second school that i went to before
transferring to my my other my final
school for high school and uh
i was just way ahead in french because i
went to french immersion and now i went
to regular school french was easy so i
was in class with people who were like
three years my age in and roasting them
on
on all the tests and exams and it was
super easy not because i was smart but
just because i was in such an intensive
program that this was easy stuff that
they were learning so i built a little
bit of a bond with her because she was
my teacher there and i think she felt
bad for me being
kind of picked on
because i'm with people who are two
three years older than me and i'm
destroying them but i'm the only one in
the class who's that young and had no
friends and so she took a liking to me i
guess and i'm grateful that my school
had that program
uh they they paired the graduating
students with
uh a teacher and the idea was that you
would meet once a week it was a teacher
mentorship program almost yeah you said
that like that's crazy um
i mean i think it's a combination of
like the students maybe didn't want to
meet the teachers and the teachers
weren't weren't pushing it because they
probably had a million other things to
do coaching classes you know clubs and
marketing and all that um
maybe i was too
you know he's like okay this is this
this is what we do
i've been asking enough questions or
judge it's like okay well i guess i'm
meeting i'm meeting her and i got
assigned her which is great because
maybe she picked me i don't even know
i it's probably actually if i think back
if like students picking kids she would
probably have picked me um it's not some
random assignment but um
yeah and i mean i had already graduate i
had already finished all the highest
level french classes by that point i
wasn't even taking french anymore
because i already finished grade 12
french like in grade 10.
um
so she wasn't helping me with school she
wasn't helping me with the content of
the material you know meeting her every
week i meet her once a week in the
morning before class started
and she would just ask me
about how things was going and
um
it just felt great and and i had my
parents who always inject me with belief
too but for whatever reason like being
in the environment having having a
teacher who kind of knew what i was
going through really helped so if i had
that a grade nine yeah i mean
what what a difference it would have
made i don't know how we
you know obviously the more customized
you can make it and the more belief you
can inject in the students the better
results are going to get i don't have
the answer for how do you do that
well it's interesting
because because like statistics show
that
75
percent of students of students who are
mentored
actually go on to graduate college or
university
um i don't you don't exactly quote me on
that right now because i don't remember
i would i was researching this last
summer and like we there's so much
importance on mentoring and mentoring
programs
yet there are
there are not a lot in
most
schools um or they wait until it's
they make it optional or they wait until
it's you know high school or 12th grade
let's get you know in the mentoring part
of that so um i just i feel that
mentoring
is such an important part of
of helping young people and youth today
but there's very limited to
to that
uh that exists right now so
um
if
you could
you know
as you were not making friends if
there's a young person today who's doing
the same thing with you right now like
feeling the same didn't have a lot
doesn't have a lot of friends or feeling
left out or struggling in school
what
what what do you say to them it's almost
like let's be like talking to your
younger self right so what would you say
to them what i would say to them would
be more just listening like i think just
being here
you know more than anything else more
than yeah like they need a friend
so
just be their friend ask them hey what
do you want to do today
play minecraft cool i wouldn't judge
them and say go do this like let's okay
let's let's go play minecraft together
let's go
to the anime conference together or
whatever you know do something to just
listen and be with them
is going to go a lot further than
telling them well you should do
x
um
what i would be looking for then is that
how to how can they find community
through the thing that they love
so how do they
if it's a minecraft club if it's a
volleyball club you know we're looking
to get in some of our you know it's a
great example my nephew
uh wants to join volleyball
you know
he was on youtube watching volleyball
tournaments and stuff he's now obsessed
with the volleyball like
how did that happen i didn't tell him
volleyball nobody told him volleyball he
just found the video on volleyball now
so now we're looking at how do we get
into a volleyball program like what's
the closest volleyball when does the
season start how do we get him in
how do we practice am i going to know
that
playing i mean yeah exactly like i i
used to play volleyball just in like gym
class but i'm not a volleyball expert
but all of a sudden now we're you know
maybe we get into volleyball and maybe
he maybe in three months he doesn't care
about anymore and now he cares about
divington or he cares about something
completely cool like i think that's
that's part of the experience
and so doing it with them but then
encouraging them
to be a part of something that they can
everything that is done solo can be done
in groups like volleyball requires it is
a team sport but um minecraft you can
join servers you can play with friends
one of the things that really helped
him was was um
doing minecraft and valor and being on
like you went from being really shy and
introverted to then doing voice comms
where you're you're on a call with the
people who are on your team
and
building friendships and learning how to
communicate and learning how to talk to
people through the thing that he cares
about instead of forcing him into right
bane class or yeah he doesn't actually
my minecraft and and fortnite and all
that because you could talk on there
with them you know it was great for my
like english language learners because
they would have to speak in english
because most of them that are there on
there and want to play with speak
english so they had to they it was it
was great i was like how'd you
where are you practicing they're like
yeah minecraft
fortnight i'm like oh good for you
it was great
well i i yeah because it's the thing
they care about
tim ferriss who wrote the far work week
had a great example we were talking
about when he's trying to learn
a new language he really loves martial
arts and wrestling and
physical contact kind of sports and so
he'll
join those groups and pick up those
books around
that style so he's trying to learn
chinese he'll learn whatever the martial
art is in china and try to pick that up
and it'll force him to learn the
language because he cares about the
thing as opposed to picking up just a
textbook on the words so absolutely yeah
i think it's fantastic like you're
trying to learn english and you care
about minecraft it's actually fun and
you want to learn how you know how do
you how do you say
right shut down that tree in english and
now you now you're look you're actually
curious about it and you research it and
you learn it so you can apply it into
your life um and that's where i think we
get a lot of things wrong is we we tend
to judge
uh the actions
if you look at our parents and it's out
of love for the most part right it's
just
we they want you to succeed
but um a lot of it i think in a in a
2022 environment is misguided because
the opportunities available to somebody
who's
even me i'm 42. the opportunity's
available with me at 42 compared to my
parents at 42 it's just a completely
different world like you can make more
money playing minecraft now and making
videos and winning tournaments than you
can be so true so true on that one um
last question
okay and so i really want you tonight if
you had to paint a picture in your mind
what does the ideal school or education
look like
i've struggled with this one i don't
have an answer i haven't spent a huge
amount of time like really think tanking
it so i would almost flip the question
like i'm curious what you think and
maybe you can add that at the end um
i think i think mentorship definitely
plays a bigger role i don't know how to
scale it i don't know if it requires
having more
people coming in more more parent
volunteers more i think less just
here's what you have to learn like most
of the stuff we learn is forgotten
most of the stuff that you pick up is
really just memorization to pass the
test
and so it's not really training us
to learn things that that matter and i
think most
i struggle with this with with my son
and my nieces and nephews was like this
is this is useless right like i'm never
going to use this right why am i
studying this yeah
you're right
i got nothing it is useless i don't use
any of this am i like the chance of you
actually finding this is pretty much
zero but it it's good building the
discipline and the structure
absolutely go do it
but it's not as strong not as strong a
message um but
yeah definitely trying to figure out
ways to teach teach kids how to learn i
think it's the most important than
teaching them what to learn like how to
learn versus what to learn is is huge um
people can learn bill gates had this
great quote
which i've been playing with um i'm
going to kind of mess it up word for
word but the idea was you can learn a
lot more when you're in community than
trying to do it on your own so even if
college or university or the school
system is not
structured very well the fact that
you're doing it together really
increases your ability to follow through
really drives up your your likelihood of
following through
which if i look at movement makers
it's what i'm trying to do is that
there's no set curriculum what do you
guys want to talk about what do you what
do you want me to talk about like what's
the theme for this
this session because i want to make
content and have discussions on what you
guys care about the most and it's never
a cus it's never a photocopy of what was
two weeks ago or a month ago or two
months ago it's always like the latest
of what i'm working on but then the
collaboration and connection between
you guys as well i think is yeah i think
is important um i i don't know that we
even need like just thinking out loud
now brainstorming while you're here like
the fact that we even put people in
groups based only oh absolutely it's
probably ridiculous absolutely because
you have different levels right your
kids are at different levels they could
be at one level math or different level
and it's something else and so
you know okay you're in
11th grade or 10th grade simply because
you're
you know this age like it's almost
almost absurd so
um
yeah and different interests
like people care about i honestly i
think i think
if you look at the club system and the
different schools that have different
clubs
you
if you look at life skills and actual
value kids probably i'm going out on a
on a uh on a limb on this one but i
would i would guess that kids get more
value out of the clubs than they do out
of the actual classes so if i go to a
chess club
and everybody there cares a lot about
chess
and it's all sorts of ages because it's
the entire school but it's only the
80 people who care about chess
and i'm learning and i'm making
connections and friendships and
strategies and i'm
i'm competing but also playing with some
of the people who are
um
at similar levels to me even if there
are different age groups i think
i think that's probably the highest
values and how do you replicate that out
and how you create
it's not even curriculum how do you
create it's you know i don't know what
alternative schools are doing but um i
mean how do you have mentors come in who
actually are living their life you know
like most guidance counselors
don't like their own life and so they're
now
giving guidance to other kids how they
should live their life
um so i do a lot more community i do a
lot more involvement i do a lot more
asking people to come in and speak i do
a lot more customization i do a lot more
mixing
of
of interests and age groups
um
a lot more action as opposed to studying
let's go out and build something make
something don't even in my even my
fourth year university course on
entrepreneurship it was just about
writing the business plan and i was
already running my business at the time
like go go and create a company
go do something go go instead of just
studying in a textbook right
but all of that requires
a completely different way of thinking
about education um but but i don't know
how you do that at scale
without a costing a thousand times more
i'm sure there are ways i'm figuring out
the scale part that's why we need people
like you
everything else that you said like for
my online school that i that i have like
it's that's exactly what it is like you
know kids aren't mixed in with each
other because why does it have to
to be just one level grade level or
another level you know if i'm having all
the kids you know read
uh build to serve then why do they have
to be in a different classroom to
rebuild the serve and to
you know then have that discussion
around it and work together to do a
project around it right and so when you
when you think about it it's about
you know
taking those doing a podcast about like
you know or having like one of my one of
my students she um
had to interview the guy that shot
archduke francis ferdinand and she loves
to do animation so she was able to do an
animation cartoon of her because she
doesn't like to be on she has her
herself doesn't like to be on camera an
animation of her
introducing him but she had to research
the theory and why he did it and all
that stuff so her questions had to be
based on that and his answers had to be
based on it but she was able to do it in
the form of a cartoon which was pretty
cool
that was high school she was in 10th
grade no let's see yeah she was in 10th
grade when she did that
so pretty cool
i think that's a killer age
i think that's a great i think you know
what that to add on to that then i would
i think you need strong
ties into the community to then give
people
internship programs
yeah around the things that they care
about because if you if you take this
girl and she cares about animation and
then she goes and does like we're gonna
say
here's what i would love to say is like
hey
ignore french
ignore music class
ignore calculus
ignore history unless it's like she
loves history and archduke ferdinand
like ignore all the stuff that you don't
care about but you still have this
basically what my parents did for me
it's like ignore all the stuff you don't
care about but you have to you have to
spend time on something that you do care
about and it's that push to go and study
and learn and be great at the thing that
you do care about and so if it's
animation for her
then
she's going to graduate high school
being kick-ass at animation in like zero
at everything else
which
how do we set her up to have success in
life which would be let's get her some
kind of opportunity either to start her
own business and animation or intern at
an animation company who when they hire
her will not care about her french
mark or her trumpet mark or like all
they care about is can she do the job
and so if you're gonna go that um
extreme in the curriculum or like lack
of curriculum customized curriculum then
then what's the next tie-in so that
they're not left
we're given in the next step so that
they're not they don't feel screwed that
well that was a fun four years but now i
can't even get into the university of my
choice
well the idea is to get them while
they're in high school that internship
and so that then for especially with the
the low-income people so that they don't
have to
everybody can go to college or
university or afford it so then they can
get jobs right out of high school
because they have a specialization in a
certain area
yeah honestly it might even be it might
even make sense to go
to go category by category you know it's
like if you look at how how did facebook
blow up well they were only for
university campuses at the beginning
and it's how a lot of companies blow up
as they start with one thing and then
they get great at that and then they
expand expand expand expand expand so
how do you build
the animation school
or the
you know acting school or the
entrepreneur school or the writing
school or the something and you focus on
getting great at that and in helping
people build projects around those
interests and then getting them
opportunities so that they're making
money in and they're set up for their
career and then add another layer and
another layer right as opposed to like
trying to do everything all at once
yeah it's probably how i would approach
it that's great well
yeah like i would do i would do
entrepreneurship for sure you know just
how do you so what's an entrepreneurship
school look like well we're going to
start businesses together
and then i'd be having a i would have a
board of a board of advisors for the
school
and the job for there is to try to get
the kids who are making
deals
you know and go get them so that they
can actually build their business when
they go i'm so excited that you said
that because
you're part of my
mastermind the entrepreneur mastermind
that i started for this coming school
year you're one of the weeks
and i use your stuff all the time i can
make curriculum out of your stuff
forever because that's what that's just
so much for these young kids to do so
i'm working on it little by little
secondary students so you're going to be
known very well in uganda as well this
coming year we have 50 kids in uganda
that we're sponsoring so it's exciting
i love it it's a huge problem it's not
one that i've spent a crazy amount of
time thinking on because i'm focused
more on kind of the entrepreneurs out
there but um
i love it i love being a part of it i
love that you're taking it on it's it's
one of the you know top 10 problems in
the world and if you fix that
you're going to fix a whole lot of a lot
of other things well we went way over
and i'm very excited that we did so i'm
just super grateful to you and
very blessed to have you in my life
thank you evan
christie right you in the house
appreciate you christy thank you
everybody for watching and we'll see you
soon if you want to see another awesome
one-on-one i did with an entrepreneur
just like you check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there